vielleicht gehe ich jetzt doch einfach
ist wie eine zeit ja ich war
hallo freunde wir sind hier gerade im
motto one hotelzimmer und das niemand
war gerade dafür wären gradl julian bams
rap video angeschaut damit überlegten
wir auch bis zum schluss gekommen
nein stimmt das war gerade saison geht
ich habe etwas gesagt man immer auf
jurist der seit dem stimmt traurig dass
sie nicht wie wir rappen
aber seid froh aber seid froh nicht
verpasst aber es wird noch besser
gewesen als rot-weiß-roten wir sind hier
gerade motelzimmer jonas auch angekommen
ich kann mir ein bisschen erzählen was
macht ihr überhaupt genau
viele fragen sich bestimmt die ganzen
post so ins programm und buch was auch
immer das mache ich da überhaupt heute
war ich zum beispiel klar sportspielen
dann war ich vorgestern war ich
fallschirmspringen und das ganze mache
ich für so eine kleine mini serie die
für clipfish produziert wird die wird
aber nicht nur auf den tisch kommen die
wird auch irgendwann mal auf einem kanal
kommen aber halt vorerst exklusiv auf
clipfish und napoli hat angefragt ob ich
da dabei sein möchte und ich glaub ich
hätte mir jemand ein zum beispiel die
oma oder die diana mit der kommt
übrigens auch morgen morgen video
ich bin immer noch ein bisschen krank
irgendwie seit monaten weil nervig ja
jona liegt es nun erstmal
die ganze nicht improvisiert wird jan
skript fix ein bisschen scheiße aber die
er merkt wir schauen wir immer noch zu
und ich habe schon wieder nichts gesagt
in dem video
denn ich habe keine video idee dafür
kommen morgen was was sehr cooles und es
wird coo und schließlich hashtag
sportlich rechtlich worte fasst
schade aber wir kommen zusammen von jona
aber ohne zug nur so komplett ohne
betonen
hallo richtige film körper hallo jona
bist du ein gast bei mekka uns im head-
vor du hast nur ein korn ferry auf
deinem background holmes ich bin ich
laut maya fanfiction simca wir uns
überlegt ob wir so ein dummes video
machen oder das versteck man ein hashtag
maler treffen luca später noch luca wenn
du das liest es ging von ihm aus als ich
hab' ich habe mich über ihr sohin
gekümmert
stimmt er ist dabei dass du unsere
beziehung zerstört ist meint lukas
meister vielleicht gehe ich jetzt doch
einfach ist häufig eine zeit aber ich
finde solche videos sind eigentlich
immer lustig aber nein und dann sehr
voll da sind wo wir hier wohnen
ich bin eine woche hier das wäre ein
bisschen einzige kommt nachher weiß
nicht oder drei jahren in welchem hotel
kann man vielleicht erkennen aber nicht
in welchem hotel wo
wisst ihr denn bisher aber das bild auf
twitter gepostet welches noch nicht und
da sieht man aber auch nichts war ja
leute das sind unsere leben möchte mein
leben hier war etwas gutes sind nicht
gut ich habe meine hose gemacht aber so
lustig wollt ihr noch sagen komm wir
helfen einfach auf den button ja was für
st